this video sponsored by hims what's up
wisecrack Jared again we saw your
request so today we're putting the crazy
hat back on to dive into the philosophy
of Grant Morrison writer of such
acclaimed works as all-star Superman
flex mental oh and Multiversity like
Alan Moore Grant Morrison was part of
the British Invasion that revolutionized
comics in the 80s and also like more
he's a self-proclaimed magician with an
affinity for psychotropic drugs to me it
just comes in a very simple equation is
the life plus significance equals magic
but there are major differences between
them beyond their obvious discrepancy in
haircut philosophy as insane as more
seems Morrison might be even crazier he
wrote some fictional girlfriends for a
fictional version of himself in the
Invisibles and then later claimed that
they appeared in real life so as a
result it's a display with my kid ofand
and it's okay I want a new one I want it
to look exactly like this Jake in their
comic she's cool
so I did I said you a monthly the ghetto
thumbs up then another one and when he
wrote about this fictional Grant
Morrison being attacked by bacterial
gods a demonic attack and/or staph
infection brought real-life Grant
Morrison to death's doorstep I found
that if if I put the character through
the situation where he was been tortured
but his lungs had bust and he was been
held in captivity and subjected till
these awful things three months later
I'm in hospital to bust lungs and dying
of blood poisoning and facing exactly
the same shamanic trial a pit mechanic
today then Christ appeared to him after
which he was healed and gained the
superpower to cure cancer in cats but
all of that pales in comparison to his
experience in Katmandu had been abducted
by aliens in count mandir in 1994 where
he was abducted by rippling dripping
blobs of pure holographic metamaterial
angels and brought to a mega medium in
which entire universes are suspended and
shown the nature of reality allegedly it
was like a burrito of religious
revelation and alien abduction all
rolled into
whether he actually ascended to a
heavenly hyperspace or was just tripping
balls is beside the point
there's a surprising amount of
sober-minded philosophy and physics that
seem to agree with certain aspects of
Morrison's Katmandu experience including
why he believes that the universe is
essentially just a giant comic book and
how he's the Midwife to an incredible
future wherein we become God welcome to
this wisecrack edition on the philosophy
of Grant Morrison spoilers ahead and if
you want to dive even deeper into the
mind of this mad genius join us over at
wisecrack plus com for an hour-long
podcast interview with the creators of
this video to be clear Morrison is not
suggesting we could ever become the
capital G God described in the Bible
Torah or the Quran you know a single
Almighty Creator of all things when
comic writers use the word God it's more
often with a lowercase G like the North
State he turned Marvel hero Thor or
other immensely powerful beings with
this logic Morrison regards of the
Justice League as the pantheon of
American mythology and deliberately
structured his roster in JLA to parallel
their olympian counterparts now we want
to be very specific in saying that he
doesn't merely mean humans will become
super-powered post humans one day he
means something much more it's Captain
Atom who inspired Moore's dr. Manhattan
that gives us our first hint as to what
Morrison means by God both captain Adam
and dr. Manhattan achieved God's status
because of their view of time they
experienced every event in their lives
simultaneously it's not that they have
perfect recall of the past and total
knowledge of the future for them there
is no past or future instead every
single moment is equally eternally real
picture a film reel as it rolls forward
at 24 frames per second the light
projects one image on the screen at any
given moment in this analogy the screen
is reality and only that single frame is
real a frame pops into existence as the
projector illuminates it and pops out of
existence as we move on to the next
frame this is what philosopher JME
McTaggart calls the a theory of time
it's how we as humans perceive time
McTaggart B theory on the other hand is
that events that do not have a
active tense so imagine if we were to
illuminate each frame of the film reel
all at once so that we could
simultaneously gaze upon every single
moment in the movie the main school of
thought among B theorists is eternalism
which claims every moment in time is
eternal from the Big Bang to the heat
death of the universe
nothing ever pops in or out of existence
rather events exist alongside one
another the shattering of this illusion
is a frequent trope in Morrison's
writings in the Invisibles Lord Fanny's
initiation into magic is accomplished at
the age of 11 when the remainder of
Fanny's life getting raped and beaten
and riyo drugged out in a drag Club in
London even eventually dying is
experienced as if it already happened
the Aztec goddess closel T O'Toole
reveals to Fanny time is not a river
time is more like a bubble but is - a
bubble what a bubble is - a circle drawn
on the ground so Morrison philosophizes
about the nature of time in his stories
cool right well he takes it further way
further - Morrison a slightly more
literal version of this B theory of time
lies in the very medium of the comic
book on any even page if we were to ask
the heroes they tell us that page and
that panel was the present moment so far
as they could tell but as the reader we
see that all the panels all the pages
all the printed issues are all equally
now their time is an illusion but one to
which we are not subjected even the
two-dimensional flat piece of paper on
which comics are drawn may be an apt
analog for the structure of space-time /
Morrison our universe may even all be a
hologram projected onto a flat mega
membrane which is in turn embedded along
with many others like it within a higher
dimensional space he's referring in his
own way to the holographic principle for
Stephen Hawking information associated
with all phenomena in the
three-dimensional world can be stored on
a two dimensional boundary like a
holographic image in a certain sense the
world would be two-dimensional like the
pages of a comic book so far everything
Morrison said seems like a reasonable
conclusion to draw from mainstream
theoretical physics and if all he had to
say was that just as a film real is a
fitting analogy
a theory so too is a comic book and apt
analogy for the B theory of time his
contribution would be entirely warranted
but then the Catman to experience went
down and things got weird
now although his more out there ideas
don't necessarily hold up to scientific
scrutiny they're still worth exploring
because they take comic books and
superheroes stories and turn them into a
compelling world view whether warranted
or not many look to figures like
Superman and Captain America for moral
inspiration Morrison offers some
justification for emulating fictional
heroes treating them as gods and even
goes so far as to say that the idea of
Superman is every bit as real as the
idea of God and suggests that we are
even more super even more godlike it's
for this reason that Morrison depicts
philosopher Giovanni Pico della
Mirandola in the pages of all-star
Superman delivering his famous oration
on the dignity of man as he later said
in his autobiography Pecos oratorio is
without a doubt earnest to go far beyond
the human into the realm of angels and
gods it asks us to accept the superhuman
as an undeniable fact of our nature and
the goal of our future evolution as a
people although his metaphors are
biblical suggesting cherubs and serifs
and Thrones as our role models and
intermediaries on the road to God or
cosmic consciousness we can just as
easily call them superheroes so what
happened that Katmandu that made
morrison believe that the universe
really is a comic book and that humanity
really is a superhero well he claims to
have stepped outside the multiverse and
seen reality from the outside the
universe the entire space-time continuum
from Big Bang to heat death no less was
not a linear shame of events with
beginning middle and end
that was only how it felt from the
inside all life on Earth was one thing a
single weird anemone like mega Hydra
with its single-celled and mortal root
in Precambrian tides a slowly complexify
increasingly self-aware super organism
it was all of us all life as seen from
the perspective of a higher dimension
whereas eternalism is content to
conclude that space-time is a timeless
four-dimensional object morrison goes
beyond eternalism by claiming that by
the same principle every human being is
actually a mere cell in a single super
organism that is humanity and therefore
if each one of us is part of a larger
whole than altruism and beneficence and
charity are in our own self-interest the
simplistic divide of right and wrong and
good and evil and superhero comics
suddenly seems less silly because our
morals aren't arbitrary social
constructs they're the Genetic
Programming instructing this super
organism not to destroy itself
indeed this view as a basis for ethics
is the very conclusion Lex Luthor
reaches when he gains Superman's powers
and upon seeing with his super senses
all the fundamental forces and how
they're interconnected he begins to weep
this is how he sees all the time every
day like it's all just us in here
together and we're all we've got
okay so if humanity as a whole is like a
superhero comic book we should therefore
behave like these costumed do-gooders
it's a compelling case but if you think
that's weird he also saw 5th dimensional
aliens or what he called mercurial hyper
sprites 5 dimensional intelligences
could as a condition of their
geometrically elevated position get into
our skulls quite easily and we can
expect their voices to come from inside
they in turn could hear our thoughts as
easily as we can read Batman's private
inner monologues on a 2d page this is
illustrated in Multiversity Pax
Americana number 1 while reading a comic
book
captain Adam muses - two scientists the
stories linear but I can flip through
the pages in any order any direction
forward in time to the conclusion back
to the opening scene the characters
remain unaware of my scrutiny but their
thoughts are transparent weightless in
little clouds this is how a
two-dimensional continuum looks to you
then staring straight ahead he says
imagine how your 3d world appears to
meet atoms fourth-wall break brings us
to another major theme in Morrison's
works metafiction allottee which is the
exploration of the relationship between
the fiction itself with the real world
of the writer and reader Morrison first
wrestled with metafiction allottee in
the final issue of his run on animal man
in which he donned what he calls a
fiction suit he inserts himself into the
comic itself to interact with the
character he notes I explained to my
character how the people who wrote his
life needed drama and shock and violence
to make his story interesting the
implication was that our own lives may
be written to entertain or to instruct
an audience in a perpendicular direction
we could never point to interacting with
us in ways we could scarcely understand
but that could be divined in the
relationship of the comic world to the
world of the creator and audience this
is the crux that connects Morrison's
metafiction to his musings on space-time
if comic books reflect the nature of our
universe can we say that the physical
comic like universe reflects the nature
of some higher reality who are our
cosmic comic creators who writes the
plot lines of history pencils the
particle interactions letters the
thought balloons of intelligent lines
Morrison's answer is the
fifth-dimensional aliens that we can't
grasp with our feeble 3-dimensional
minds but he admits the particulars are
less important than the implications
that follow from their being intelligent
designers if the analogy of our universe
being like a comic book extends so far
as to suggest that it has something like
a writer then the mere fact that it is a
written work implies a purposefulness to
our existence now of course being
created doesn't necessarily impart
dignity we might be like Morrison's
animal man with all our suffering for no
greater purpose than to provide drama
and a piece of cheap entertainment we
might be made by a hack our whole
purpose might be to pass butter but
contra his younger self when writing
animal man the more mature Morrison
became more optimistic in Flex meant
hallo man of muscle mystery Morrison
once again used metafiction ality as a
means of exploring questions about our
own purpose just as Morrison sees
reality as having a three-tiered
structure with his fifth-dimensional
imps at the top the 2d comic-book
characters at the bottom
and us in the middle so too is the story
of flex mins hallo set across three
levels of reality there's the cartoon
world of flex mint hallo the realistic
world of flexes writer Wallis sage an
avatar Morrison himself and yet a higher
reality inhabited by superheroes more
real than their writers or the fifth
dimensional aliens in the story it's
revealed that superheroes instead of
being merely a product of the
imagination of writers like wall-e were
in fact the beings that created Wally's
entire world after which they retreated
into the imagination ceding our culture
with superhero stories in anticipation
of the day that mere mortals are ready
to become like them as a result humanity
only needs to resolve their uncertainty
about whether superheroes are real or
not and decide to believe them into
existence here Morrison is suggesting a
much more dignified purpose to our
existence we're meant to discover our
fundamental purpose in the pages of
comic books and to believe into
existence the idea of the Superman to
incarnate him in ourselves for Morrison
the medium of comics and the plot
structure of superhero stories are so
closely connected in our culture because
both are parts of the same pattern that
explain everything else in existence in
recognizing this pattern Morrison writes
his own autobiography super gods in the
style and structure of an archetypal
superhero story including a secret
origin in Glasgow the call to adventure
a top cat man - and a death and rebirth
in which he brings the hidden knowledge
he gained on his hero's journey to the
comics community and while that hidden
knowledge is parsed out in piecemeal and
his comics writing it's in super gods
where he's most explicit about just what
makes humankind itself a super God
already we can see humankind is having
all the attributes of comic book
superheroes or even pagan gods
whereas Mercury carried messages at the
speed of thought to the Roman gods
we have instantaneous interconnectivity
via the Internet whereas team dolls
all-seeing eye could spy everywhere in
all nine realms our satellites can zoom
in on any spot on earth like Superman
we've flown faster than a speeding
bullet
humanity when viewed as a whole is all
a super God insofar as there is no
future frames of the film reel popping
into existence we are not becoming this
super God we already always are this
epoch of human history is merely its
secret origin story as to how it gets
its superhuman powers but all of its
ongoing adventures and never-ending
battles to come are all already written
published printed and on the shelves of
some higher dimensional comic shop if
mankind is this super organism with all
these stupendous powers who's supposed
to act according to the simple morality
of a super hero whose whole history is
structured like a superhero story and
who's living in a cosmos that's
constructed like a comic book
then Morrison's obvious conclusion is
this mankind's purpose is to be a
superhero it's for this reason that
Morrison calls the Sun God from
Smallville our greatest ever idea as the
human species not because Superman was
the prototype on which all other
superheroes would be based but because
he is the template for which the super
god of humanity must become all-powerful
and all good all at the same time this
is the summation of Morrison's
philosophy articulated best by jor-el -
his one and only son regarding the
essential truth about man and Superman
and not the mankind within the comics
but the mankind reading comics you have
given them an ideal to aspire to embody
their highest aspirations they will race
and stumble and fall and crawl and curse
and finally they will join you in the
Sun kal-el but hey whether or not we
accomplish wonders the doctors who work
with hymns have come pretty close hymns
has created a personalized and private
online store for men to get
recommendations from real doctors for
fda-approved prescription and
non-prescription products without
leaving home what kind of products you
ask well look guys some things are
difficult to discuss with a doctor
hair loss affects two out of every three
men by age 35 and thanks to science
baldness can now be optional hims offers
medical grade solutions to help treat
hair loss
Kym's is offering wisecrack viewers a
full month trial of their complete hair
kit up to a sixty seven dollar value for
just five bucks while supplies last so
head over to for him
calm / wisecrack or click the link below
to get your discount today and big
thanks to hims for sponsoring this video
and to Grant Morrison for being even
crazier than Alan more peace guys
[Music]